see outside
mags label with the [ __ ] governance
grill
this is what I'm talking about is bad
and [ __ ] I love you with all my
heart do a sexy girl Joey cocoa busy at
the airport
my business rates and jokes Dickinson
company policy at TSA right here doing
that thing I'm over here
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
they're right there like me [ __ ] see
me the dumb [ __ ] black my thing New
York Buffalo was great I'm about to get
my luggage to take a look at this guy
this is Ali's cousin there either this
guy with the [ __ ] world new thing
this is definitely one ascend duskies
[ __ ] victims is half a [ __ ] freak
this guy with the Irish in Oklahoma [ __ ]
an Arab over here look at this chick
good times with the [ __ ] hat what
does she going it's a beautiful thing
here for like that
beautiful day to be alive what's
happening beautiful people Joey Diaz
North Hollywood Park with my beautiful
wife pregnant wife we're walking the
track trying to get some oxygen to the
baby trying to melt the fat off my
[ __ ] fat ass that's it this how you
do it is North Hollywood Park that's the
trail this is all the stuff the little
flowers it's a beautiful park here it's
on a Tujunga and Magnolia we're gonna
start doing fat man walks and stole the
grams and meet here on Saturdays and
smoke the bone and walk around the track
you guys wanted me to let you know I'm
doing with the exercise and I'm here
that's all that matters have a great day
mad flavors well and doc damn is
acupuncturist of the future company got
it all right so this is Joey getting his
cups and the cups are really good for
blood circulation and the lung strength
it's very good for muscle pain here you
go here's your Joey back that's right
[ __ ] so you put these cups on it
takes out all the bad spirits out of
there the warmth the whole thing I do
this fix the circulation darling doctor
he's happy he's insane who loves you
more than me stay black matte flavor
world and [ __ ] hollywood check
it out bosses [ __ ]
people white hats on look at these
[ __ ] beauties down here it's still
early so you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on look at this little a Koppel
and this [ __ ] mom over stopping
traffic this is the stupidity I gotta
put up with the [ __ ] Hollywood clean
this guy's picking garbage can this be
the end
how you doing [ __ ] look at this
guy with the pink [ __ ] show yeah
right I was a teenage [ __ ] Batman get
the [ __ ] out of my face look at these
[ __ ] mamas they go on a trip to
Disneyland how you doing all right
vote for me [ __ ] mad flavor divine
wellness the king of the [ __ ] edibles
right here on my man it's gonna make
loving let's go in there and see what
they got for us and [ __ ] yeah divine
wall there's more the best spots on
[ __ ] Lancashire look at that goddamn
boy right there welcome to the violence
let's look at that [ __ ] Church HBU
the [ __ ] selection look at that [ __ ]
we [ __ ] around here and they got bang
[ __ ] chocolates look at that
boom boom boom come on the [ __ ]
banana bread right there pumpkin
brownies lemons wholemeal cookies that's
how we do it you see that [ __ ]
look at I've even got [ __ ] sodas
little [ __ ] but zookas oh Jesus pipes
[ __ ] vaporizes he's not talking about
guys all right these little hash
capsules this is the spot right here
I never bust your balls I always give
you the best parts to go to here's my
man McLovin always taking care of me bad
[ __ ] say hello Big Love and
looking gonna tell that's the man right
there so you come to the vine want let's
tell a meth flavor century all right and
ask for Big Love and stay black tell me
what's that tell me what's up
mmm-hmm tell me what's up I love you I'm
still acupuncture doc Tammi doing her
thing she got a few needles my leg
that's thick enough to work the mean see
one to another one right there
just to get the swelling down and give
it some general health
that's what acupuncture does for your
few non-believers
get it together [ __ ] myself and dr.
Amy yeah make it happen make it happen
stay Jewish this [ __ ] Mook dirty with
a [ __ ] skateboard look like this is
Hollywood welcome to [ __ ] Hollywood
here under this poor [ __ ] lady over
here
in the traffic here [ __ ] always
[ __ ] around call from my
haircut here with the Russians look at
the [ __ ] head do I died it the other
day with the Koreans now for a haircut I
gotta go to Russians I don't even know
if this guy's [ __ ] Russian I just
call him a Russian he's on the Russian
Nate but he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
we are man [ __ ] legend the man
Gabriel a bad [ __ ] here Mauro
Matt flavors well as my brother I love
this [ __ ]
stay black concept is the puppet war
bullets back [ __ ]
people always asked me in such a good
mood in the mornings you play music what
the [ __ ] is your secret you know what my
secret is and I walk among the rooms and
I see this I see these three guys who
kind of their brothers and sisters the
two boys in the front of brothers but
the girl on the back of sisters and when
I walk in the room and I see that after
all these years they still cuddle and
they [ __ ] hang out and [ __ ] that's
what makes my day that's why I get happy
cuz I did a good [ __ ] job with these
little three [ __ ] you follow me
there from two different mothers but the
same father and still today eight years
later they get along they love each
other they sleep together that's what
it's all about it at the end
much less
[Music]